are we are we there yeah do you have our
dolls
i i don't have the the figures um i
don't think that they've actually been
released
oh okay now so a few quick questions for
you if you if you if the eternals had
been able to fight thanos
on their own do you think that they
could have won
yeah
absolutely yeah
i like that confidence
yeah
um
i am curious though when you guys got
involved in tina would have taken him on
her own thank you
right to be honest after watching the
movie that could be true
i
completely agree when you guys were
talking with marvel and with chloe about
your character uh characters did you
guys ever get in this discussion of like
how powerful is each person you know how
much like did you ever have that debate
she had lots of questions
because i had to fight so i had to
figure out all my
you know even fighting icarus and saying
so but wait if i do if i can i bounce
can i bounce his eyes back at him with
my shield can i
do you know you have lots of questions
because i listen so so in the
in the comics and if you look us up all
of us have every power
or something like that it's some
extraordinary thing but so which is no
movie right it's very i think it's one
of those very smart things that they did
was they said these people can't these
characters won't be able to challenge
each other or this movie will be over in
a minute if everybody can do everything
and everybody's supremely powerful so we
kind of divided
um
the the skills a little more than what
was in the past and so we you know i
can't fly he can't have weapons this
person can't do this and then that
um that was a very smart it had to be
that way we were divided into groups
ones that were more physically you know
they had super powers that were more
physically that were for battle and some
that were more intellectual powers you
know like transformation or me healing
that were not
so much for typical for war
which but they were used to win
everything you know so that i think that
was really interesting
i gotta say i was kind of disappointed
because
i didn't i i can fly in the comic
but
you will see i can kind of
i'd like you to fly blind no yes you
should glide not she'd be great at
gliding yeah and if she could fly then
for sure she would get i'm gonna take an
icarus yeah
um which of your friends and family were
the most excited that you were joining
the mcu
my
husband for sure
shamelessly
he's so excited and he didn't come to
the perimeter but he's going to say oh
he's going to see it in london yeah
um
i i think my kids were both excited and
then you know when you love these type
of movies but then suddenly mom they're
right
it's kind of maybe blows the blows the
doors open on your your fantasy when
it's your mother
who's suddenly like
but but my kids do they i'm very
fortunate that i'm very close to my kids
so
they were very they were very supportive
of me as dina i think it was more like
they were helping me than just fans
they're like you can do this and they
were so proud i saw them at the premiere
we were coming one by one and i'm trying
to say hello but they're ignoring me
because they're waiting for their mommy
to come out
and i i will never forget this it's one
of the most memorable moments of the
when she came out the way their faces
lit
oh it was really beautiful
just a lot about you
uh my life all right we're talking oh
sorry my last question for you guys i
love learning the behind the scenes of
the making of movies and shows what do
you think fans would be surprised to
learn about the actual making of
eternals
well it was an interesting combination
of
using all the technology
but also making it
really
grounded and
all style film making probably like the
depth of the the actual work that you
would
the the fun part you'd you'd imagine the
the kind of magic of the the weapons the
swords the the fights the flying that
stuff i think you know but for this one
i think it was more really heavy talks
about
life and earth and humanity and
sexuality and spirituality and things
like that i think and that was
that was surprising and we liked each
other we had fun we had parties like
halloween parties and silly things we
we we became a family we we still do
on that note i got to stop i'm just
going to say thank you for your time i
hope the film is a huge hit uh have a
great day thank you